mali's army moves in but arrives too
late three days after the attack in the
bankas commune of central mali the
al-qaeda fighters are long gone
this is what is left of a once bustling
market over the weekend young men on
motorbikes armed with machine guns fired
indiscriminately most of the people in
the village were shot dead after days of
continuous gunfire there's an eerie and
unsettling calm what's lingering is the
smell of charred bodies al qaeda
fighters burned entire villages as
families slept in their huts hundreds of
people were killed in an attack that
lasted 72 hours
an uncomfortable gathering the survivors
faced the army that has again failed to
protect them they struggled to hide
their grief and anger they had called
for help in the early hours of saturday
morning why didn't the malian army
that's supported by russian fighters
intervened wonders this man
and where were any of the 14 000 un
peacekeeping troops that have the
mandate to protect them so many
questions left unanswered by the
authority
why when you are alerted do you not
respond on time but just after the
tragedy this worries us a lot because we
call before the attackers arrived yet
these people are afraid even of a mere
noise from a plane
the governor responds saying malians
have to be patient and that god willing
there will be peace
while no one has claimed responsibility
malian authorities believe the fulani
preacher ahmadu kufa who heads a local
al-qaeda affiliate orchestrated the
attack
this is the beginning of the rainy
season and fulani herders encroach on
farmland to feed their cattle with
increasing numbers of droughts the
malian army accuses al-qaeda of
fermenting ethnic tensions between
fulani herders and local farmers
the lesson we have learned today is to
be patient and avoid violence against
each other we did not inherit this from
our ancestors it is new violence that
has crept in
the number of people killed in attacks
by armed groups in mali has doubled in
the last year attacks are spreading
beyond its borders to neighboring
countries the malian army seems
overwhelmed and one step behind these
armed groups that many fear are gaining
ground in central mali nicholas hawk al
jazeera